tsa confiscation list from last year
will leave you without means to fight a
bear that did not rhyme yes your airport
delays make sure the machete stays tsa
released a list of items they took from
travelers in 2021 including a chainsaw
fireworks machete and a burrito filled
with meth
finally a burrito that helps you lose
weight
now i get why those things had to go but
some other stuff on the list like a wine
holder shaped like a gun and a container
of bear spray made less less sense funny
story i once mixed up my gun and my wine
holder that's why i'm putting my
sommeliers kids through college
rip sommelier the officers who took the
bear spray are really lucky however that
there was no grizzly attack on the plane
or else they'd feel exceptionally bad
bear spray is like a plunger don't be
without one when you need one anyway
airports don't seem to be getting any
less crazy in 2022 just check out what
this guy tried to board a plane with
over the weekend
uh mr devito i really can't let you
board this time oh come on the tsa just
worked me over 40 minutes i'll tell you
the same thing i told them this
underwears prescription and i'm cleared
to fly well let me show you the items
we're taking at security
a rotary telephone
an actual gun
a toaster
and whatever the hell this thing is
none of these things were found inside
of my luggage mr devito these items were
taken during your cavity search
oh
there you go you didn't think we're
going to make a joke like that do you is
there any policy loftus what is the
policy do you go to jail if they picked
i don't know not if you're aaron sorkin
you can go through with with cocaine and
mushrooms and all kinds of loaded
weapons and burbanks just says you get
out of here and go right now is that
true oh you don't remember that i don't
but then i don't remember a lot of
people but this is this is the tsa just
justified their existence to me
like it seems like they miss everything
and now at least we got entertained a
crystal meth burrito come on i know
that's the best you gotta franchise
that's a great idea hiding stuff cat you
still don't the tsa no you fell for
propaganda because this list of the top
things they found is probably really a
list of the only things they've got
that's true yes yes that's true like
there's been so many studies and it's
like oh they missed 80 they missed 95
percent they missed 95 again but we're
still paying them hundreds of million
like just all this money for what it's
doing they got to go buy tsa we could
figure this out on ourselves right tyrus
or what you know i think sometimes we we
underestimate how great the tsa is
because they find water bottles anywhere
i mean they have compensated enough
water bottles to literally make a lake
they they're on that doesn't matter if
it's for your baby it doesn't matter if
you know if you need it because you're
thirsty because here's the good news
once they take it away from you they'll
they give you you can drink it now
or you throw it in the trash so they
give you an opportunity then here's the
here's the crazy part you literally walk
out through security and stop at a store
and buy what the same what exact size
watermelon
yeah for eight dollars yeah so who's
that really about i i feel conspiracy
here they do the same thing with lube
they say you gotta throw it away or you
can use it now
i'm not getting on that one
that was a good joke dude that's a good
no that's a good joke i was just
thinking about you know
using it as moisturizer don't mind if i
do let me put some lube on my face i'm
gonna just pour the lube in my pocket so
i don't throw it away it'll be there
when i land i have a feeling if gut phil
got caught with lube he could just stare
at the guy and the guy be like you know
what just go
let's go just go well that's my strategy
going through when they try to pull me
aside i'm like do it do it
but they're bragging like they're a
chainsaw they're bragging about finances
yeah i know i know how how hard was that
yeah exactly and it was that it was
actually from a chainsaw construction
company it was like yeah these
warning chainsaws on the side it's not
like you can slide it in your carry-on
bag it's a friggin chainsaw so but you
know we look at covid we i think we've
learned a lesson here that once they
government
institute rules they don't like to
un-institute them no i think we're
seeing that right now hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else